my name is Ria ludwava I'm the current
chairperson of transformation Committee
of sports in South Africa and the
provincial head of women in sports
it's always a struggle for women to to
come up you know in in a male dominated
because Sports it's it's still male
dominated the challenges are that uh
women come into those boards and and
they basically do not add value because
their silence specifically by by the
fear of just raising their issues in in
that Community Committee if there could
be more funding for for women in this
country and I'm not talking only circum
talking Sports in general I think we we
have seen over a period of time that
they the success of this country comes
from women what I've seen when they came
in 2004 and what I see today I can tell
you that I wouldn't be surprised if they
go to the next knockout stages and
that's where I wish they should go to
The Knockout stages because I know
they've got resilience we have seen them
giving Sweden a hard time Sweden won but
it was it was not an easy win so and
Sweden is number three in the world
South Africa is number 54. remember the
African Champions and and when you are
an African champion and you go to the
World Cup you must bring that out you
know you there are four African
countries there Morocco Zambia and
Nigeria and South Africa but what comes
out there is South Africa is the
champions of the continent of Africa so
they must bring that they must show
Europe that Africa it's up to the
challenge